for the first time in history  a marginalized group has a huge dollar  sign on the top of their head  we have five  children's hospitals in the united  states  promoting that  that's a phalloplasty that's a bottom  surgery  we have five children's hospitals in the  united states  telling girls  that they can be boys  at seventy thousand dollars a pop in a  surgery that has a sixty seven percent  complication rate that will kill me from  infection that i can't sue on  we're butchering a generation of  children because nobody's willing to  talk about anything  i have three kids  at the age that they're doing this to  kids  i'm not transphobic  i love my kids and i love other people's  kids and you should too  this is wrong  on so many levels